Good morning, Hank!
Hi, Hank!
Hi, Hank! Hello!
Good morning, Hank.
Good morning, Hank!
I can't just say good morning, Hank.
JOHN: Julie.
Yes?
JOHN: Will you say "Good morning, Hank?"
I'm gonna make Good Morning Hank above 700 librarians?
Will you say... will you just?
Good morning, Hank.
Not above 700 librarians, Hank but, alongside with them.
CROWD:
Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
That was a pretty great "Good morning, Hank!"
Hank, a lot of great things happened at the American Library Association conference this weekend,
And if you're wondering why you're looking at this very strange shot instead of any of those great things
like me hanging out with Judy Blume, or me going to a lot of fun parties,
It's because I accidentally taped over all that stuff with 30 minutes of this stuff.
AAAAAAAAGGGHH
Stupid!
Fortunately you will get to listen to me harangue a reader.
JOHN: Are you a dumper?
WOMAN: No.
JOHN: You're only friends 'cuz he wants you back.
WOMAN: No it was mutual, actually.
JOHN: It's never mutual!
WOMAN: I was just the first-
In fact pretty much the only things I have footage of are
Nerdfighter Cynthia Lord winning the Newberry Honor
for her book "Rules,"
And the Printz Award reception on Monday night.
SPEAKER: When I returned from midwinter in Seattle, I was alerted to check out the Brotherhood 2.0 website
[applause and laughter]
Where John got a video of THE phone call. It was fun to see his happy dance over the good news,
and tune in again the next day to see John's brother, Hank, toast him with
"Here's to silver medals — to... not quite doing as good as you did last time!" [audience laughter]
Hank, ALA Convention is always fun, but this one was particularly fun because it was so Hank-tastic.
Everywhere I went, people were like
"Hey, you're Hank Green's brother!"
And I was like
"Yeah, I also write books!" And they were like
"...right, but you're Hank Green's brother!!"
Four different people asked me if I knew your phone number, and I was like
"He's my brother. Yes, I know his phone number."
And they said, "Can I have it?" And I said, "No!"
People kept telling me how cute you are, and how funny you are, and how much they like you.
So, Hank, if you like young adult literature so much,
I would encourage you to write some of it, because you're bound to be an instant hit.
All the Printz features were great.
Markus Zusak, Tobin Anderson, Gene Yang, and Sonya Hartnett all were wonderful.
I don't know how I did, but here's the funniest snippet. I'll let you judge.
People still think of librarians as these shy, retiring flowers.
Whenever I hear someone stereotype a librarian like that,
I always counter their inherited story with a true one of my own. This is entirely true.
I say that last year, at a librarian conference in New Orleans,
I learned how hard librarians party during an evening of casual gambling. [audience chuckles]
When I happened across a librarian
passed out drunk,
sprawled across the loud carpet of Harrah's Casino,
a spilled drink in one hand,
and a galley of a promising first novel in the other. [laughter and applause]
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow.